الخط الساخن او الهاتف الاحمر مصطلح اثار
جدلا واسعا بعد عدم رد كوريا الشماليه على
اتصال تجارتها الجنوبيه لليوم الثالث على
التوالي فماذا نعرف عن هذه التقنيه الخط
الساخن او كما يعرف ايضا بالهاتف الاحمر
يستخدم للاشاره الى كل انواع الاتصالات
المباشره بين البلدان او السلطات بشان
مسائل حساسه وامنيه كذلك يطلق هذا المصطلح
على خدمات اتصالات الطوارئ كالشرطه مثلا
اول خط اتصال ساخن مباشر تم اطلاقه في عام
1963 بين الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
السوفيتي لتسهيل الحوار وقت الازمات بين
قاده البلدين هذا الخط اعتمدت دول حول
العالم كالصين واليابان والهند وباكستان
فيما يوجد بين الكوريتين اكثر من اربعين
خطا ساخنا افتتح اولها في عام
1971 وتمر معظم هذه الخطوط الساخنه عبر
المنطقه الامنيه المشتركه الواقعه في قريه
بانمون جون الحدوديه